قال قائد اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل
ثلاثه من جنوده برصاص شرطي مصري واضحا ان
منفذ الهجوم قتل جنديين اسرائيليين فجرا
عند معبر العوجه على الحدود مع مصر قبل ان
يتبادل اطلاق النار بعد ساعات مع قوه
اسرائيليه ما ادى لمقتله ومقتل جندي
اسرائيلي اخر واصابه ضابط
وقال قائد المنطقه الجنوبيه في الجيش
الاسرائيلي الجنرال اليعايزر توليدانو انه
هو منذ اللحظه التي تم فيها اكتشاف جثتي
الجندي والمجنده الاسرائيليين صريعين في
موقع قرب الحدود مع مصر تم التعامل مع
الحادث على انه حادث ارهابي واضاف في
تصريحات قربه معبر العوجه على الحدود مع
مصر ان هناك ما وصفه بتحقيق معمق بالتعاون
مع الجيش المصري بشان الحادث
يجلس هناك الكثير من الاسئله داخل القوات
العسكريه نجري تحقيقا معمقا كما نجري
تحقيقا مشتركا مع المصريين حول هذا الحادث
من بدايته حتى نهايته وفعلا هناك الكثير
من الاسئله
من ناحيته وصف رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
الحادثه في رساله حكومته بالاستثنائيه
لكنه قال انها لن تؤثر على التعاون
الامنيه مع مصر في المقابل قال الجيش
المصري ان عنصر امن اخترق الحدود اثناء
مطاردته مهربي مخدرات وادى تبادل لاطلاق
النار الى مقتل ثلاثه اسرائيليين
من رام الله معنا مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد بدايه هناك
تضارب بين
الروايتين المصريه والاسرائيليه
نعم هناك تناقض هائل بين الروايتين مصر
تقول بانه كان في عمليه مطارده لمهربين
وانه اطلق النار واسرائيل تقول بانه تسلل
واستهدف جنديين لها هذه الروايات لن تحسم
الا من خلال لجنه التحقيق المشتركه التي
اعلنها قائد او رئيس هيئه الاركان
العسكريه في الجيش الاسرائيلي انه تم
الاتفاق عليها مع مصر من اجل ان يقوم
بتحقيق متعمق لنهايه بطاقه كشف كافه
الملابسات التسلسل هذا الحادث الذي يعتبر
استثنائيا كما وصفه نتنياه ويصفوه الجميع
بانه بدا بعد ان كان هناك
احباط لعمليه تهريب النحو الثالثه والنصف
ومن ثم بدات
نحو السادسه وصلت معلومات الى قياده
المنطقه الجنوبيه الى القوه المسؤوله وهي
القوه 80 او اللواء 80 بان هناك دوي سماع
دوي اطلاق للنيران في محيط نقطه للمراقبه
الاسرائيليه على الحدود في المنطقه
الغربيه الشماليه على بعد ثلاثه كيلو
مترات من معبر العوجه
وقال الجنود والجند والجنون مجنده انهم
يبحثون لمعرفه مصدر هذه النيران لكن انقطع
حسب الروايه الجيش الصين انقطع الاتصال
بهما ومن ثم بدات عمليات التمشيط بحثا
عنهما لم يعثروا عليهما الا بين الساعه
الثامنه والتاسعه صباحا بمعنى انه بعد
ساعتين الى ثلاثه تم العثور عليهما قتيلين
رميا بالرصاص في المنطقه على منطقه قريبه
من برج المراقبه بعد ذلك تحول التعامل مع
هذا الحادث وفق قائد المنطقه الجنوبيه او
اللواء الجنوبي في الجيش الاسرائيلي الى
عزبه لدانه الذي اكتشف قواته والمسؤوله عن
الحدود مع مصر ومع قطاع غزه ايضا بدات
عمليه التنشيط تبحث
عن التعامل السياسي مع الموضوع بالنظر الى
ان حتى هذه المنطقه تعتبر من الامن في
الحدود المصريه مع اسرائيل كيف تتعامل
اسرائيل سياسيا بحدود السلام بين مصر
واسرائيل لان هذه الحدود نصت على اليه
التعامل معها اتفاقيه
معمول بها بين الجانبين في اطار اتفاق
السلام سياسيا التصريح الوحيد صدر عن مكتب
نتنياهو ورئيس الوزراء الذي قال فيه بان
الحادثه استثنائيه لكنها لن تؤثر على
العلاقات مع مصر باقي التصريحات اشارت الى
ان التحقيقات مشتركه ستكون اسرائيليه
مصريه لكشف الملابسات لكن حتى هذه اللحظه
ليس واضحا
الاسرائيليين لا في الروايه الاسرائيليه
ولا في الروايه المصريه ما هي الدوافع
التي كانت وراء الشرطي او الرجل المسلح
المصري وما الذي دفعه اذا كان فعلا تسلل
كما تقول اسرائيل وما الذي جرى وهل هي
كانت فعلا مطارده لمهربين لان المنطقه
معروفه بانها تشهد الكثير من عمليات تهريب
المخدرات وبعض الاحيان الاسلحه ويتم
احباطها في الكثير من الاحيان كان المعدل
سنويا للمحدرات التي يتم تهريبها هناك 60
طن نزلت الى 20 طن في السنه الاخيره شكرا
لك من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري